[Music]
well for me reinvention is really being
able to take something that already
exists break it apart and put it back
together in a better way and add in some
of your personality to it and everything
you've learned along your life
[Music]
to be fair I always had a high
expectation of the American college
system I mean when I first came in all
the resources were there in terms of
libraries and computers and Printers and
so forth but the actual digital
experience was not where I thought it
would be they were still using clunky
portals from the 90s learning management
systems that were pretty prescriptive
that weren't really engaging students
the way we were engaged in other places
of our lives I saw a problem that I felt
compelled to solve I just felt that I
knew the problem I experienced it
firsthand so I really wanted to help
shift education to move towards that
direction to move into a more
user-friendly experience for everybody
in the digital era that we live in today
during my college senior year I was
actually taking a course that allowed us
to consult for a company outside of the
campus so when I did that consultant
project I was really focused on what I
wanted to do and I wasn't really
performing in that class surprisingly
enough the CEO of the class asked to see
me I thought I was gonna be in trouble
because I was really performing and he
just asked me why are you so busy we
were clearly working but you're not
working on what we need you to work on
and that's when I told him what I was
working on I showed him how I wanted to
reimagine education and the company that
I was working for was all about
reimagining things around design and
innovation and the CEO fell in love with
with the idea and actually told me he
wanted to reimagine it as well and since
then he became one of our lead investors
in the company one of the avid
supporters of a be up till this day and
I was pretty interesting turn of events
there's always going to be some people
that will disagree with your business
sometimes the majority but if you really
believe in what you're doing you're
trying your best really try to talk to
as many people as possible you'll always
find someone if the business is worth
doing that that will invest in your idea
so don't give up don't give up after
five six seven phone calls try again a
hundred times
[Music]
you